hi I'm Jimmy Kimmel and I'm the host of  the Oscars this year you know I get so  many letters from people asking me how  do I win one of them and well first  thing you have to do is get a job as a  waiter mozzarella sticks and your side  of down-home don't mind if I skip thank  you next you have to go to a lot of  auditions I don't care how allergic you  are senator there's no law that says  that a dog can't be president that's  actually true and finally when you do  get the role  you have to act your little heart out  and all goes well the Oscar goes to you  I would like to thank my shaman Laurie  don't forget to thank your mother oh  yeah thanks mom  and also keep it sure I have things to  do and thank you to the Academy oh it's  just that simple  the Oscars where you going with B Oscar  that's not yours  live February 26th on ABC  that's not yours